[Musique]
bonjour mes ami e
quel beau temps c'est vraiment l'été qui
arrive et l'été c'est agréable car il ya
les grandes vacances à voir les vacances
aujourd'hui je sais que vous avez été
très gentils des enfants ont fait des
bouquets de fleurs d'autres des paquets
surprise mais oui aujourd'hui c'est la
fête des papas du papa c'est aujourd'hui
ta phut petit papa c'est bien gros
source
je suis sûr que p'tit louis et mirabel
ont préparé une très belle surprise pour
l'heure pas parus et europe là je veux
vite voir ça peux-tu papa c'est
aujourd'hui ta phut dis papa c'est un
job dit appelle un deal pas bassa
tombeau du taf a montré qu'un cause ou
ce regain de la belle surprise qu'on a
préparé pour notre papa c'est un grand
livre qu'on a dessiné tout seul pour lui
pour sa bibliothèque il est très beau
voyons voir ça de plus près ti 20 nov ça
se passe dans le pays vous êtes allé
voir les dragons il y avait une fois une
petite fille chinoise qui habitait dans
une petite maison un papier chimie et
avait de belles robes en papier de
toutes les couleurs il y avait plus la
même valeur dans son jardin
tu vois des rouges et des bleus c'est là
c'est moi qui les ai dessiné un jour son
papa était malade il était très malade
et le joker est venu l'oeuvre
le pauvre homme le docteur lui a dit
monsieur vous êtes bien malade
c'est pas les oreillons il sait pas la
jaunisse mais vous êtes très malade
alors la petite fille qui était christ
et darrigand garde comme un être une
loison la pauvre petite chinoise pour
faire plaisir à son papa il est allé
chercher les fleurs de son jardin
il en a fait un beau bouquet il les a
donnés à son papa ne sont pas ici guéri
et on appelait séjourne à la fête des
papas à ce vraiment une très belle
histoire et votre livre est magnifique
votre papa va être bien contents
[Musique]
tu sais maintenant quand notre peuple
viendra nous embrasser dans notre lit
avec notre maman devant lui dire à
pareille fête en a pas bonne fête papa
bonne nuit les enfants dorment et vite
à demain en une heure de l'est
[Musique]
p'tit louis et mirabel sont vraiment
très gentils et leur papa doit être
content j'espère que vos papa avoue eux
aussi sont contents à ce soir bonnut des
enfants embrasser encore bien fort votre
papa est aussi votre maman est allée
vite vous coucher en automne ours
bonne nuit à demain à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
vous
e
oh